the reading is extremely interesting i
greatly enjoyed Jose's sophisticated and
complex piece I would quibble with in a
very minor way the there's as he says at
one point that American Protestantism
has never had much tension with
capitalism and I think broadly true but
there was a period in the 30s when the
social gospel of Jesus Christ which my
father was a Protestant minister and he
was trained at Yale in that gospel and
when I was a nine-year-old the newspaper
in our small town in the Midwest one
morning had a headline Reverend Ray
found to be communist
so I've seen some tension the Taylor
piece I think it's I think it's a kind
of lay down hand that there are multiple
modernity's there of course there are is
a dichotomy between cultural and a
cultural theories it disappoints me
because and it's just about impossible
to have an a cultural understanding that
one takes seriously it's a bit of a
straw man and he's a bigger intellect
them needs straw persons and following
miroslav following Taylor following
Casanova let's think of a culture as and
i'm just going to distort this slightly
just to make it a little clearer for
what i want to say as a an understanding
of the self and society of thriving and
rectitude right and wrong a theory of
agency theory of how one's wishes and
needs are realized or aren't realized
and a theory of cause and effect the
what why do things happen as they do and
doesn't have anything to do with our
behavior and finally a theory of death
what is death what what's that all about
and I we can obviously extend this list
at length but secularism is a very
abstract category and in the middle of
secularism is a culture that could in
some respects be mistaken for a religion
the Yale Law School is one of its
seminaries the school management is
another of its right that's it school
management is also a seminary the school
of medicine is also a seminary and
here's an act of faith this is the pill
for my arthritic knees and I believe
that that pill will extend my agency by
allowing me to walk more comfortably and
that's it it is an utter conviction of
mine based on my belief in experimental
science that that pill is about as good
as any pill i can take short of opiates
and i might prefer opiates because i
think they would work better but the
doctor doesn't agree what is this faith
it is partly a theory about property
rights and this book by Hernando de Soto
is an extremely elegant laying out of of
that idea the second it is a theory
about the division of labor if you think
about Adam Smith and the pin Factory and
so on but this is a much more elaborate
theory with deeply specialized expertise
laid out across a very wide spectrum
from science and engineering to the
study of religion and culture to what
we're doing which I guess is that this
afternoon it is a it includes a
commitment to utilitarianism endian john
paul's piece the little piece we read
there's a passage where he says not all
ethics does our worthy of the name and
then he says what he means is
utilitarianism and of course the trouble
with utilitarianism
is what as many troubles but it does
squash the interests of minorities where
the greatest good of the greatest number
goes in another direction and it
conflates dignity with a mere preference
and I think he's kind of right about
that but utilitarianism for for better
or worse quite possibly worse as in the
middle of this theology or this culture
I'm talking about and the notion of
economic efficiency is part of it
whereas I pretty confident about the
pill that I just swallowed I'm less
confident about efficiency is the
ultimate criterion for how we run the
world and the for me personally the the
the there is also and I think it thanks
this is fairly true most people who
subscribe to this church this faith or
this non faith if you will I'd it's not
important to me to lay claim to that
word there is a transposition of
religious belief and I think Jose's
paper kind of hints this idea my wife is
I'm not an atheist my wife is an atheist
and she comes from a long line five
generations of Presbyterian ministers in
her lineal family and she is as good a
Presbyterian as you'll find anywhere on
every question except God right she I
mean she has absorbed all of it in with
great rigor and in great detail and uh
and with great personal discipline she
believes all the right and wrong stories
and and yet she is a priestess of what
I'm talking about she runs a big
institutional investment fund for the
Carnegie Corporation and she has
absorbed all of this and I've and I have
absorbed a good bit of it so the
question of where the collisions with
faiths properly understood and there are
two places and at three places where the
let's just call what I'm talking about
market secularism if you will I don't
quite what the right name is one is in
theories of agency how do i get my knees
to quit hurting i am i know people who
pray for their for their own health and
the health of their family and friends
and I respect that but I think pills are
likely to work better and ah and that's
that's a point of theirs ultimately a
real contradiction there it's not you
can t lead that I don't think second the
myth of the myth or theory of our
origins the book of Genesis against
natural history and the secular regime
has a powerful not altogether comforting
story one that most of us I came to
subscribe to it thoroughly by about age
ten reading children's versions of
Darwin and that's a another point of
friction last in theories of thriving or
accounts of thriving and rectitude the
market secularism has in it a bunch of
good many rules for example about
telling the truth
telling telling the truth and not
committing fraud of keeping promises
honoring contracts but there are a bunch
of other rules that doesn't really have
right the notion of a monogamous
marriage and all that for example I
there's no particular commitment one way
or another in in that doctrine so it's
incomplete in that way and and it may
well be that the hedonism of our popular
culture is consequent to that I'll stop
there